this is what they look at this morning
okay now this is the first these are the
first two lines of an integral we looked
at look at little we go please
we looked at this and I picked this out
as an example because we noticed when we
had a look at this pair of this product
that would try to integrate if you
looked at it and no matter which way you
sliced it up
integration by plants good one it hated
you and it can lead to you thank you
remember that well this is the this is
what you came up with basically you
either got this or plus this by the way
it lets you either way it was something
which we looked at thought that's not a
standard for me what do I do it but we
didn't give up we've said well let's
just let's just give it another go so
indigent integration by parts once which
gives this line and then we saw okay
I could actually added this secondary
integral I could do integration by parts
okay and what's a lot of got spawned out
by this had a relationship to the
original integral do you remember that
what do come in second dinner tell me so
so I guess my point was that wouldn't
you do integration by parts right and
particularly when you have like say
these these powers or these three
integrals often you're getting integrals
that are related to your rigid or water
right and that was another problem we
saw that you can actually resolve that
and I was kind of cool now that idea of
integrals leading to integrals is going
to be our bridge into today's concept so
I'm going to introduce you to this
question know a few here okay this is
all
okay now in just the same way as we did
before when you're not purchase as
integration by parts so it's a it's an
obvious choice for interior parts
because you've got a part that's just
kind of staring you in the face so what
would you let me choose for U and DV or
DX
you're suggesting DV or DX to be okay
that's a great choice why is that a
smart choice okay because that is like
we say Oh try and choose this not just
so that the green arrow is nice right
but so that this is easy to integrate
and this is this function to integrate
right so there you go which of course
leaves us with x squared here so you got
two X coming in over there okay so it's
so far so good you do notice that if you
want to do it in Reverse if you place
easier T and still get e to the X there
right because it's derivative we get but
you get something dramatically worse
good morning on this second row right if
you said DV Odette's if you let that
equal x squared then when you integrate
up you're getting executed on three
that's making the problem worse rather
than better okay because the degree is
going to pop so this looks good I'm
happy with this so let's take this and
bring it into our question so I bought
you V which is x squared
yeah by this integral of V D u so I've
got a soother I'm actually gonna put
that out the front since it's a constant
X DX
okay now this is very similar to the
problem that we just did because I
already just kind of alluded to the fact
that if you slice up a different way
it's not better so this is as good as it
gets but the edge of relax idiot is what
we've seen before like this comes up at
extension one this is a classic
differentiate accident yes only hence
integrate don't know luckily but has
extension to students we can handle this
without any clues what are you going to
do with this
just like before we're going to do it
directional parts again right so be that
I've got this as a second area under
user a new color I've got you
do you X I know you could actually
introduce a on a new pair of names for
this F of G or whatever you like but I
think this would be enough for our
purposes okay again what should I choose
my dude and by debate okay let's just do
it again right it went so well for us
last time I've got a to the x over here
which means by V will be e to the X
you've got X here and you've got one now
just pause for second before you put pen
to paper and bring that into our
integral right do you see what's
happening as you've gone through step
one integration by plants to step two
integration by parts do you notice that
what you've got is like because of this
e to the X theme it just kind of stays
the same every time
but successive applications of
integration by parts they're reducing
the power here to here to here do you
see that so it's getting better and
better each time and now when we
actually do it this in or incorporate
about I should say you can see converted
it see this is actually quite nice so
I've got my X e to the X stay up front
take away 2 and then here comes my new
version my red version of UV take away
the integral of V du u right so let's go
ahead and run this there's UV take away
okay so I'm sort of crabby about wearing
a shirt like a sample space but they go
what's happy
what are we done well after the first
step we degrade her parts and the second
step what went down left with you is
something which all the way through I'm
gonna highlight for you all the way
through this stream of integrals are all
connected right but the great thing here
which is even nicer than the example we
saw up here is that this is I can just
evaluate that right but I have done
through successive steps of integration
of my plants gotten down to something
reduce the problem down such that cool
I don't even need integration by
passengers this is just a simple simple
thing to evaluate so let's go ahead and
finish it off
I've got x squared in the X gift I've
got 2x e to the X there and I'm gonna
add there cuz I've got a BB give to EDX
plus a constant
are you happy what do you think that's
good and one last thing that it's not
necessary but I can't tidy this up I see
you're close to the factor all the way
through you so I'm just going to pull
that into the X and I'm left with this
quadratic in the brackets so what do we
done here right we've gone through this
number of steps of integration by parts
I had to do two integration of my past
twice why was it twice why have to do it
twice it's true
the first time you got this and then the
second time you got this right but after
that you didn't need integration by
parts anymore what it was really
connected to it was we're gonna
highlight it right it's it's this power
up here you see it was - and then it
became one and then it became there
actually is an X term hiding here it's X
to the nor right so you can now imagine
all right suppose I had started with
this took us about two steps of
integration my plants to applications as
it were if I've made this set X to the
five great X to the five I've been evx
bit that stays the same all the way
through but this is the plot that
reduces so if I had X to the 5 I'd have
to do this five times if I had X to the
500 I have to do it 500 times okay so
whenever math would you need to see
something like this it's like cool I see
a pattern here we want to generalize
right we want to say well what if the
pattern power was anything you like